in this video you're gonna learn how to
find the lateral area as well as the
surface area of prisons cylinders cones
and pyramids so when we talk about
finding the lateral area in the surface
area sometimes it's helpful to group the
prisms and the cylinders together
because the formulas are the same and
we're going to group the cones and the
pyramids together because those formulas
are the same so when we're talking about
lateral area what we're talking about is
the area of the sides okay when we're
talking about surface area we're talking
about the total area so not only the
sides but the top and the bottom so what
I did here just to kind of illustrate
this is I took a sheet of paper and I
constructed it into a square prism it's
a square prism because at the top and
the bottom the two bases that are
parallel and congruent our squares and
so what we're doing when we find the
lateral area is we're taking the
perimeter of this square here okay and
when we unfold this this is the
perimeter times the height gives us the
area of this rectangle now this
rectangle let me fold this back up again
that's giving us the lateral area the
area of the sides to find the surface
area we just have to take that lateral
area and add the two bases so you'd find
the area of whatever this shape is times
two since you have a top and a bottom so
let's do that in example number one see
if you can do this on your own and we
can follow along together here as well
so here if we want to find the lateral
area I'm going to take the area of this
I'm sorry the perimeter of this base
which is going to be 4 plus 4 plus 4
plus 4 that's 16 and I'm going to
multiply it by 10 so that gives us a
hundred and 60 centimeters squared now
if you want a visual on this I imagine
if I was to take some scissors and cut
it like right here and unfold it this is
what's referred to as a net it would
look like this and you'd have 4 4 4 4
with a height of 10 so you can see this
is 16 times 10 that's giving you the
area of the sides the lateral area 160
centimeters squared all we have to do
now to find the surface area is take
that lateral area
okay so la lateral area 160 plus the
area of the base times two since we have
a top and a bottom now you can see this
is a square four times four is 16 this
will also be 16 so that's gonna be 2
times 16 that's 32 plus 160 is a hundred
and 92 centimeters squared okay it's
like if you were covering this with like
little 1x1 square centimeters that's how
much would cover that outer surface okay
so that was kind of an easy one let's go
to number two a little bit more
challenging what kind of a shape do you
think this one is well this one is a
triangular prism see how the top and the
bottom are triangles they're separated
by that height eight so when you deal
with cones and pyramids you just have
that one base with a prism you have
these two bases that are parallel and
congruent so let's talk about the
lateral area first we want to find the
perimeter of the base okay so that would
be the perimeter of this triangle then
we just have to multiply it by the
height so in this case we only know that
this side is three and this is four how
can we find this third side of the base
well because this is a right triangle we
can do the Pythagorean theorem so you
probably remember a squared plus B
squared equals C squared so this is
three squared plus four squared equals C
squared this is nine plus 16 which is 25
and if we take the square root you can
see that that missing side here is going
to be five so now the perimeter is going
to be 3 plus 4 is 7 plus 5 is 12 okay so
the perimeter is 12 times the height
which is 8 so that's going to give us a
lateral area of 96 inches squared if we
want to find the surface area and now we
just have to add these two bases on here
see the area of the base times 2 and so
because this is a triangle though we're
gonna have to do 1/2 times 3 times 4
notice that the height of the triangle
is always perpendicular to the base so 3
times 4 times 1/2 so that's going to be
12 times 1/2 is 6 but because we have
two of those triangles we're going to
double this so 2 times 6 is 12 and if we
add that to the lateral area which
96 we get a hundred and eight inches
squared for our surface area which is
the total area now another way to do
these problems especially with the
prisms if you get confused if you get
stuck if you don't like using these
formulas you can always find the area of
each face you know each polygon and add
them all together but sometimes using
these formulas it's a little bit quicker
a little bit more efficient so you might
want to memorize these and what I like
to do too when I'm doing this is I like
to write the formula down and then write
below each variable I can substitute in
what I need and proceed from there just
to keep everything organized so I'll
show you another a couple examples with
prisms and we'll go on to the cones and
the pyramids okay number three what kind
of a shape do you think this one is well
it looks like a prison because we have
the two parallel congruent bases and it
looks like they're hexagons because they
have six sides so this is a hexagonal
prism but the question is is how do we
find the lateral area and the surface
area of this hexagonal prism well let's
start with the lateral area so again
what I like to do is write down the
formula first lateral area equals the
perimeter of the base times the height
so here notice these markings that tells
us that all the sides are congruent this
is a regular hexagon
so if we take 6 times the six sides
that's 36 so that's the perimeter 36
inches times a height which that's the
height of the prism that's 4 so 36 times
4 is 144 and that'll be inches squared
so that's the lateral area there is of
the sides all we have to do now to find
the surface area is add on the area of
the base times 2 because we have a true
basis so let's go ahead and do that so
surface area equals lateral area 144
plus 2 times the area of the base now
how do we find the area of a hexagon
you've probably learned in an earlier
lesson that the area of a regular
polygon we can use this formula 1/2
apothem times perimeter
if not you can check out my video on an
area of regular polygons but here what
you can see is 2 times 1/2 is 1 because
2 is like 2 over 1 so these cancel so
really all we have to do is figure out
the apothem and then the perimeter well
we know that the perimeter is 6 times 6
which is 36 the apothem mill is gonna be
right here let me draw this a little bit
bigger so here's the hexagon and you can
divide this up into triangles but the
apothem is this perpendicular distance
to the side so if this is 6 right here
that means that each of these are going
to be 3 and because I was able to make 6
triangles and see how this forms a
circle 360 divided by 6 is 60 degrees
but when I drop that altitude that
apothem I ISEC to that angle that means
that this is a 30-degree angle so it's a
30-60-90 triangle so we have to remember
our special right triangles as well so
if this is 3 that means that this side
right here the apothem is going to be 3
times the square root of 3 so that's
what we have here a 3 square root of 3
times 36 is how much 108 square root of
3 so an exact answer would be for the
surface areas 144 plus 108 square root
of 3 inches squared that's the total
area you can do this on your calculator
if you want a decimal approximation so
we use a lot of formulas in this example
they have 1/2 apothem pants the
perimeter we also use special right
triangles and we also had to use these
formulas but the key is if you can know
the general formula then what you can do
is you can always break it down further
into like the sub formulas okay so less
to memorize that way let's go over to
the cylinder now so how do we find a
lateral area and the surface area of a
cylinder oftentimes in math classes
they'll give you these formulas
separately but if you use what I'm
showing you here it'll make it a lot
easier so lateral area equals the
perimeter of the base okay times the
height now the perimeter of this circle
is another way of saying the
circumference of the circle
circumference and perimeter they're the
same right in a circle so the
circumference we know is 2 PI R ok so
that's the perimeter and then times the
height so we know the height is 12 and
we know that the radius here is 4
so if we multiply all that together
let's see we get 2 times 4 is 8 times 12
is 96 times pi so it's 96 pi centimeters
squared and just to show you a visual on
that see let's make a cylinder out of a
sheet of paper here so here we have okay
a cylinder right but notice this
circumference right that's the perimeter
of the base if I take some scissors and
I cut this this is the perimeter that
was a circle times the height that gives
us the area of this rectangle and that
rectangle is what makes up the lateral
area the area of the sides okay so now
all we have to do is add on these two
bases to find the surface area so we've
got surface area equals 96 pi plus 2
times the area of the base but the base
is a circle what's the formula for area
of a circle
well that's PI R squared right so that's
gonna be 2 times pi times the radius
squared 2 times pi times 4 squared which
is 16 and so that comes out to 32 pi
plus the 96 pi is how much that's a
hundred and twenty eight PI centimeters
squared that's the total surface area
that's how much paint you would need if
you wanted to paint this entire can
right okay let's go over to cones and
pyramids next okay number five we've got
a square pyramid and we want to find the
lateral area the area of the sides as
well as the surface area which is like
saying the total area which would
include the bottom the base so when we
work with cones and pyramids these are
the two formulas that we're going to use
for both of them that you can kind of
group those together clones and pyramids
the lateral area we use one half the
perimeter of the base times the slant
height so what exactly is the slant
height well see how the size of this
pyramid are made up of triangles it's
the height of one of those triangles you
don't want to get confused you don't
want to use what they call the lateral
edge okay you don't want that height
meaning the distance from this vertex to
the center of the
okaythat's use that when you find the
volume you really want just the height
of the triangle this is your slant
height you can think it is like L for
like leaning okay the leaning height so
that's what we're after here so now the
lateral area let's write our formula
down lateral area equals one-half
perimeter the base times the slant
height the perimeter is going to be two
plus two plus two plus two so that's
going to be 8 and the slant height is
six so if we multiply that together 1/2
times 8 is 4 4 times 6 is 24 units
squared okay so that's since I didn't
label the units there now for the
surface area we just have to take that
lateral area plus the base so the area
of the base is just a square here so 2
times 2 is 4 so the surface area is
going to be 24 the lateral area plus the
base which is 4 remember there's just
one base not 2 like in a prism and if we
add those together we get 28 units
squared for our total surface area now
for number 6 we've got a cone cone in a
pyramid they look very similar the only
difference is that the base here is
actually a circle right and then the
sides are really not not made up of
triangles like here if you wanted to
just find the area of the four triangles
and then add the square you would get
the total surface area here it's
difficult to do like if I was to cut
this cone and unroll it it wouldn't form
like a nice polygon shape like a
triangle or something like that so this
is where the formulas are really going
to help us with the cone so let's start
with the lateral area so lateral area is
1/2 the perimeter of the base times the
slant height so the Elam's like that
leaning height that's slant height
that's 5 we don't want the 4 that's the
overall height we use that when we find
the volume so we've got 1/2 the
perimeter of the base times the slant
height which you can see is 5 but the
perimeter of the base that's a circle
which is really like the circumference
hmm so we want 2 times pi times R which
is a circumference excuse me so 1/2
times 2 those cancel that's just 1 the
radius is 3 and the slant height is 5 so
if you multiply that together we get 15
PI units squared that's our lateral area
the area of the side
now if we want to find the surface area
all we have to do is add on that base of
course the area of the base here this is
the area of a circle that's PI R squared
so we've got surface area equals lateral
area which is 15 pi plus the area of the
base which is PI R squared the radius is
3 3 squared is 9 so we get 9 pi plus 15
pi is 24 pi units squared and that's our
total surface area if you want to learn
more about lateral area surface area of
these polyhedron as well as the volume
follow me over to the giant review that
I did covering all these shapes surface
area lateral area volume and I'll see
you over in that video right there